what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
man aliens nightmare asylum is good it's
one of my favorite stories from the
alien line of comics the issue with this
is that between alien outbreaks or the
video that we did last time and this one
there was an actual novel like an actual
book with words there is why I say that
as a lot of people are like do you mean
graphic novel because that's just a
giant comic book but then it was an
actual novel and we can't really do like
novels per se but that one was called
earth hive and all that really
established was the idea that earth was
completely overrun by xenomorph now of
course we knew that I guess we could say
like Billy and her you know billion
wilkes but it's basically it's mutant
Hicks um we knew that their characters
had traveled back to earth after the
events of the first book after you know
the events of outbreak an attempt to
basically get back home only to find out
that the entire earth had been overrun
with xenomorph now of course we covered
why in the last video so you guys are
welcome to check that out but in their
desperate attempt to escape they
basically stowed away aboard a vessel
called the USS s American and following
their departure all they really receive
which mean the time that they got on
this vessel and left Earth's orbit and
to the time that they basically you know
ended up at their pre pre programmed
destination we're just a series like a
smattering of transmissions from Earth
but there was no rhyme or reason it was
just whatever broadcast happened to be
sent out and it was really just an
absolute massacre on earth it was
absolutely insane the implication here
is that in a moment of desperation the
governments of the world launched
nuclear weapons we don't know that for
sure it's just kind of tossed out there
a couple times but I haven't seen
anything to actually verify that that's
the case but if they did it would have
made sense just because with the threat
being so extreme and aliens reproducing
as fast as they do the earth was little
ran in a matter of months because keep
in mind between the time that Newton
Hicks boarded their vessel to return to
Earth you're talking about over a year
in travel that's why they have you know
cryostasis and so on so they'll
basically you know sleep for the journey
instead of aging over the course of the
journey and so because that once once
they got back to earth essentially
around a year had passed and over the
course of that year the earth was just
overrun in his entirety I mean there
were queens everywhere there were drones
everywhere and so those individuals who
could make their escape did of course
they ended up going to Gateway station
the station that we saw from from aliens
the the second alien movie for the most
part almost all of humanity was pushed
to the brink of extinction now it's kind
of crazy to see this
because it's it's everywhere I mean
there's no symptoms of order left
there's no Earth Defense Forces there's
no government there's no nothing it's
people just making their way as best
they can now of course this also kind of
Dell's with the idea of beulah keep in
mind Bueller was the synthetic who I
guess but the person who seemed like a
human being only to turn out to be a
synthetic but Newt had fallen in love
with him because give him our on this
takes place around ten years after the
events of aliens and so because of that
uh Newt after learning that Bueller was
a synthetic when he was torn in half and
really kind of sent her life into a
tailspin in the sense that in her mind
the one man that she had ever fallen in
love with turned out to be an Android so
he was never really a man in the first
place now initially it doesn't change
how she feels about him in the sense
that she's still very much in love with
him but it's time progresses she kind of
has to come to grips with the fact that
Bueller was never a man at the same time
Bueller himself is having a hard time
basically coming to grips of the fact
that he's a synthetic and this really
tells us how far the programming goes on
these things that in some cases I mean
not all of them were like that but in
some cases be synthetics you're
programmed to believe that they're
legitimately human now of course we know
and aliens that like Bishop like he knew
he was a synthetic he knew what he was
programmed for he knew what his purpose
was but in this instance Bueller didn't
know he thought he was a legitimate
legitimate human being and then suddenly
there was this you know they went to the
alien homeworld and then he was torn in
half only to find out that he was a he
was a robot so again it kind of creates
a very confusing situation for the two
of them and they're both trying to
essentially rectify their own individual
feelings now at this point it really
begins to delve into this idea that Newt
has this sort of connection with the
Xenomorphs that nobody else seems to
have innocence she actually has a dream
that she's back in her room and that
Hicks forces himself on her but in the
midst of this Hicks basically explodes
outwards with a full-grown alien now the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that it's almost like a warning
sign it's almost kind of like like a
radar going off or something like that
that whenever new did you know whatever
she has these terrible you know I guess
we can call her Billie just for the sake
of a comic but whatever she has these
premonitions it means that the
Xenomorphs are not far behind and so
right off the bat she's tipped off to
the idea that there are Zeno Mors that
have gotten on board now the funny thing
about this is that how this is done is
played fast and loose I mean we're not
giving this super complex explanation
because they were on the xenomorph
homeworld so we're kind of left to our
devices to come to the realization Zeno
Mors could probably see I'm sorry
they were on earth rather as it were
kind of left to come to this realization
of the xenomorph you know some of them
had probably just stowed away on the
ship when Dillian and Wilks left earth
and you know they just kind of been on
the ship ever since but the idea here is
it's really more of just kind of an
exercise in getting them off the ship
it's not a super complex story there's
really not a whole lot to it
there's really just kind of fighting for
their survival and essentially that's
kind of kicking them off they jettison
them to the airlock it really goes to
the whole of the ship and just kind of
finishes them off and that's really it
but the reason why this is significant
and the reason why this matters is
because they actually end up finding out
that they're pre-programmed destination
was a terraforming facility on another
planet and the issue with this is that
once they get there they end up finding
out the entire military operation has
basically been co-opted by a guy named
general Spears now general Spears has
essentially lost his mind he's a man
that's gone insane immediately after
after billion will show up here we end
up having him basically say hey look uh
you guys are going to be interred you
guys are going to be thrown in jail and
the reason why is because of the fact
that the specimens on board the vessel
we're going to be taken by General
Spears for the purpose of basically
weaponizing them turning them into
soldiers but because of the fact that
Wilson and Billy you know we're just
going to call them Hickson neut all
right I'm sorry like we're not going to
call them Wilson Billy that's stupid
because of the fact that Hickson knew to
basically destroy those tube aliens
general Spears views it as sedition he
views it as an act of really an act of
mutiny against his authority so because
of that they're really just kind of held
in stasis and they're going to be used
for the purposes of breeding in the
sense that Spears is going to intend to
implant them with aliens and allow it to
kind of go free now we won't really find
out the full lengths of what he did in
order to get to where he is now we won't
find out about that for the next a
little bit but at this point we
basically switch over to a guy named how
now how is as close to a
second-in-command as a person in get to
general Spears just because of the fact
that he views himself as absolute leader
and everybody else under his authority
which is true to a degree but there are
no other ranks for low General Spears in
terms of how he views himself
everybody is effectively a private
everybody is effectively just a soldier
doing their job but the other idea here
is that again the facility of Spears is
just monitoring all these transmissions
but what Cowell says is that because
Spears has basically lost his mind there
are those who are loyal to him and there
are those who are not and what it is
going to do is it's going to lead to a
revolution now what this does is it
basically leads to a hand
other guys who are intending to launch
this campaign this campaign for the
purpose of essentially trying to take
out general Spears now the way they
intend to do this is by traveling to the
terraform a terraforming colony for the
purpose of contacting the people who
were there basically establishing a
resistance and then using those vast
numbers to try to take down general
Spears but again that's actually going
to prove to be completely unsuccessful
but what we end up doing is we basically
transition back to the idea of newt
having these empathic powers and general
spears had effectively learned about
this not only that because of the fact
that he's basically been doing research
on hicks
he now knows about the history of hicks
with regards to the first time he
encountered the of the Xenomorphs during
the first aliens movie so again this all
really kind of harkens back to the
aliens film really harkens back to the
second movie the greatest of all of them
all the alien movies that have ever come
out but the fact remains here that what
uh what what Speer says is that in his
mind you know they're basically just
organisms they're just creatures they
just exist they follow orders the orders
come from their queen but they just
follow orders but it's kind of funny
because what he says is that during the
initial outbreak on earth during the
initial infestation in the early days
that the Queen's were popping up all
over the place right because that's how
the Xenomorphs functioning we'll get to
that when we get to the story about how
like Queens you know have the hierarchy
and all that kind of stuff works but
when it comes to the xenomorph the
queens have this impact acclaim with
their drones I mean that was established
in the second movie that was established
with the idea when Ripley goes stumbling
into the hive of the Queen you know only
to look around and just be like oh crap
there's eggs everywhere like you know
when the Queen basically told her drones
to stand off that was when the empathic
link was established and so what what
sphere says is on earth they picked up
with the exact same thing they realized
by the queen is the one that issues
orders so conquering the drones means
conquering the queen and conquering the
queen it means forcing her to understand
that Spears is the one that has control
that he'll kill her drones if she
refuses to follow his orders now we'll
see the lengths she goes to to make that
happen but it's basically this idea that
Spears is trying to find a way to turn
the Xenomorphs into soldiers so he can
send them back to earth and retake the
planet now on the surface it seems like
it's an idea that has merit right like
you know if the Xenomorphs have taken
over earth then use you know more to
take the earth back the problem with
this is that it's a stupid idea
we know
that's ridiculous we know that many
people have tried many groups have tried
to weaponize a xenomorph and they've all
failed every last one not only that it
usually led to a massive outbreak and
the xenomorph went crazy and basically
decided propagating and reproducing like
Ravis so because of that it usually
never works now transitioning back to
these broadcasts kind of a funny thing
is we get this little girl and we get
her uncle and what is up happening is
the two of them really just kind of
giving us this play-by-play of what's
going on on earth in the sense that in
all this devastation that most people do
not take residents and buildings instead
they stay outside and the reason why is
because humanity learned that the
xenomorph are almost impossible to spot
when they're inside buildings because
there's no electricity there's no light
the only light you have is the light of
the Sun and the light of the moon
whenever you know whatever the skies
clear so because of that most people
don't know the Xenomorphs are there
until the screaming starts and then
everybody just runs everybody just
panicked and everybody hides but again
it also brings into question the idea of
how xenomorph see people and of course
well we'll cover that later on when we
get to the whole you know reproduction
Queen Queen Theory or whatever it is
that story's called but the fact remains
here that when it comes to the whole you
know that the whole facility the powell
despite being the second in command and
despite being the guy who basically
follows the orders of spears without
question he's the guy who's actually
planning sedition he's the guy that
actually says look we need to get rid of
spears because he's going to lead to the
death of us all because he cares more
about his pets than he does about people
than about his soldiers and so again
transitioning back to these soldiers to
these these guys who are looking to
plant this revolution who have arrived
at the evah terraforming colony it's
exactly what we would expect the whole
colony has been overrun by xenomorph now
how they were overrun we don't know we
simply know that the entire colony was
overrun and everyone there is dead now
following this it's a repeat of aliens
yeah memories we are living if that's
like my favorite scene from aliens it's
a repeat of just the shootout from
aliens I mean it's it's a massacre like
none of them were prepared and that's
what it's designed to be right like the
Xenomorphs are designed to be it is
insanely evolved efficient killing
machines when they swarm on you and mass
numbers Katie bar the door because no
one's going to make it out a lot it's
just one of those things where it's just
death just death and blood and and
weird slime stuff that they use so
because of that these guys are taken out
pretty quickly but we end up finding
there are there is actually one or two
survivors that managed to make it out
the problem with this is that Spears has
become aware of their campaign travels
over to the terraforming colony and
refuses to let them leave and keeps them
locked in there only for them to be
consumed by the Z no more snow at this
point we picked up with everything that
was going on in terms of what he was
doing to get to this point what we find
out is that because of the fact that
spheres wanted to weaponize the
xenomorph what he needed was a queen he
needed to be able to have his own queen
that could produce a whole ton of
xenomorph because he couldn't just go to
earth and snatch one up by then they
were all full-grown so because of that
these things standing 20 to 30 feet tall
you can't just grab one you know we
needed to give birth to a live queen the
only way to do that was to basically
bring in eggs now once this Queen was
propagated among the different different
colonists it was taken by general Spears
and it was allowed to grow to maturity
and then started producing offspring now
what he did in turn was he basically
grabbed the colonists and then he sort
of putting them in these little
isolation pods
basically going to them and saying hey
look there's this massive outbreak
there's this viral contagion that's been
taking place here and the terraforming
colony we're here to keep you guys safe
we're going to keep the quarantine for a
little bit we're going to make sure
everything checks out if it does we're
going to clear out the colony and you're
going to go back it's the perfect ruse
showing up there under the guise of
protection for the purpose of furthering
his own agenda and so with each of these
individuals contained within one of
these isolation cubes he also kept the
Queen in full view of everything that
was going on and what he would do is he
would unleash the xenomorph onto each of
these people but then as soon as the
Xenomorphs killed that person he would
kill the xenomorph and the message that
he was trying to get across to the queen
is they attack only when I tell you to
have them attack if I tell you do not
attack then they don't attack if they do
that I'm going to kill them now the
funny thing about this is that the Queen
understands what it is he's doing that's
one of the whole aspects of the Queen is
they're smarter than the average bear
right like I mean they're they're pretty
smart if they're pretty intelligent you
know they're not communicative they're
not going to have an in-depth complex
explanation with an alien queen but they
do understand the queen is able to pick
up what it is that general Spears is
putting down and so because of that the
queen basically began sending commands
to the drones you know when when general
spears basically says do not
have them attack the Queen calls them
off they're attacked now the sadistic
nature of this is that general Spears is
just experimenting on people
experimenting on average individuals but
he's not the only one to do that we
switch back to this little girl and her
uncle with a various broadcast that
they're sending out and one of the
broadcast shows that there are different
religious groups who have effectively
lost their minds you know some of them
are these religious groups that already
existed the ones we saw in the first
first video some of them are new
religious groups in a sense they all
look at the xenomorph as their gods so
to speak and so what they do is they
basically drag whatever humans they can
find they drag them to the Queen
so that the human can be implanted with
an alien and the idea is that what the
Queen loves you the Queen wants to be
with you know the king wants to make you
one of her own that kind of thing and so
they don't really look at it as though
people are being killed and new
xenomorphs are being born
they look at it it's people being reborn
as Xenomorphs their essence their soul
what it is it makes them who they are
it's being you know brought to life in
the form of a xenomorph it's absolute
insanity I mean this was just complete
and total madness but when the
insurgency begins to pick up you know
when Kyle when Hicks when Newt basically
begin the process of this sedition and
effectively begin to take over this
military base the loyalists of general
Spears of course turn against them which
leads to the firefight but the problem
is that in the process the Queen is free
now we know as lovers of the Alien
franchise now when the Queen gets free
that means things are getting ready to
pop off that means that things are going
to get bad really really fast and that's
exactly what happens here
that's exactly how it plays out at this
point the Queen is on a warpath I mean
she's not even reproducing right now
she's just going through and just
wreaking absolute havoc now that's the
way it functions when it comes to the
Xenomorphs the queen is the prized
possession it's like a termite Queen
right like it's hidden away from any
form of danger now it doesn't mean the
Queen is vulnerable I mean we know that
the Queen is probably the deadliest of
the xenomorph in an immediate hi the
city we know that does not take into
account like Queen Mother's or Empress's
or anything like that or even the alien
king if we choose to go that route when
it comes to the Queen's they are wildly
deadly and so because of that in this
scenario it's really more of instinct
it's more of animal prey now the Queen
is a little being a little vindictive
here you know in a sense she's just like
everyone's going to die but the fact
remains here another Queen his funk is
carrying out her basic function clear
out the area of any potential danger
make sure nothing's there anything that
is there capture it and bring it back
for breeding and then she'll begin the
process of laying eggs now what happens
with the Queen is that once she leaves
her ovipositor
which is to say once she basically
leaves that giant egg sac
she can't reattach to it she has to make
a new one and so that one will basically
just die off whatever eggs are planted
will just more or less kind of decay and
go away but a new ovipositor will form
and the Queen will begin the process of
kind of you know propagating the the
xenomorph species once again the issue
with this is that pollen hits are
waiting for spears to return now their
hope would everything that's going on as
crazy as it is their hope is that when
he returns he'll run headlong into
xenomorph and be completely conquered
the issue with this is that he comes
barreling in in a massive tank and
basically begins taking out all these
different Xenomorphs but in the midst of
all this Buhler effectively wakes up and
this is when he really becomes the guy
that engineers their escape and the
reason why I say this is because
remember he's a synthetic and the
Xenomorphs don't tear about synthetics
they care about Biological organisms
they can propagate their species it's
one of the reasons why they just don't
pick up on synthetics they just don't
care they just don't worry about them
and so because of that well this whole
situation is unfolding well you know you
have powel and you have Hicks and you
have you know these guys trying to lead
a revolution against fears and so on
Bueller is able to make his way to the
to the to the actual control deck and
essentially you know allow Hickson and
newt to get away from the Xenomorphs by
shutting off doors and different things
like that effectively allowing them to
get to the airlock and then board one of
the vessels that's leaving via the USS
MacArthur cave a problem with this is
that the McArthur is being piloted by
Spears and the idea here is that in his
mind he's going to take these Xenomorphs
back to earth he says look we're ready
we're ready to grab the Xenomorphs and
we're ready to get back to earth because
remember in his mind what he's been
doing is when the Xenomorphs learn to
follow orders from the Queen he takes
those Xenomorphs and he puts them in
stasis because now he used them as
trained soldiers he used them as
individuals that will follow his direct
orders the issue with this is that for
Hickson Newt they kind of realized it's
a lost cause in a lot of different ways
now of course Bueller basically sends
off a last-minute transmission to Newt
saying look you know I'm sorry I've
loved you you know I love you I'll
always love you that kind of thing you
know basically saying goodbye but once
general Spears is on his way back to
earth hits the new basically grab an
escape pod and bail out to Gateway
station now
funny thing about this is that on the
journey back to earth general Hicks is
getting fully dressed up in his
traditional general uniform you know
like the whole nine yards because in his
mind he feels like he's going to lead
this massive rebellion to take back
earth well he's got to get the American
flag you've got him peanut with his
traditional sword a ceremonial sword you
mean the whole nine yards like you know
soldiers attack the problem with this is
that the xenomorph follow instinct and
really they follow their queen and at
the end of the day the Queen was born at
night but she wasn't born last night
and so while you know general spears was
issuing his orders and while she was
following him down to a teep it was a
rout she was playing the long game you
say look I'll follow your orders now but
as soon as I get the opportunity I will
take you out and that's exactly what
happens right here that's exactly what
happens with Xena works immediately turn
against him the Queen makes your
presence known and we that's when they
essentially find out that she was just
kind of leading him on the entire time
and so of course easy no more basically
attack you know generals fears he's dead
and that's the end of him his rebellion
basically comes to an end before it even
started and the earth remains overrun
with xenomorphs and so because of that
we have Hicks and we have new arriving
back at Gateway station this story
essentially wraps up and we have you
know this uncle and his daughter you
know communicating the last of the
transmissions basically saying hey look
they're building some great big huge
giant hive here on earth I don't know
what it's for I don't know what it's
about but as the story begins to wrap up
we end up finding out that of all the
survivors from Earth they managed to
make their way back to the space station
one of them was Ellen Ripley but that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explain make sure you hit
this sub button to become part of the
Rob forth you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]